[Music]
we'll begin with breaking news from
Guatemala where anti-corruption
center-left candidate Bernardo aravalo
has won the presidential runoff election
now araval Iran on a platform of
fighting corruption in a country dealing
with both corruption and violence
marvala was on the ballot with
Conservative candidate Sandra Torres
well Al jazeera's Manor rapalo isn't
live at a polling station in Guatemala
City and talk to us Manny about this is
really a surprise win for an outsider
candidate is that right
good to be with you Kimberly yes look
this is an absolutely ecstatic
environment that we're in right now in
Guatemala's historic center with people
celebrating if you could hear that it is
just an absolute party in Guatemala
City's Central Plaza I think for our
team none of us were expecting the
results to uh come in as fast as they
can I'm going to read you these latest
results because we're still at at
97.7 percent of the votes counted 58 of
58.6 of those votes going to the
center-left candidate Bernardo as you
said a political Outsider despite the
fact that Arevalo is the son of
Guatemala's first democratically elected
president he is he was still seen here
in Guatemala as a political Outsider as
the sort of Dark Horse who came out of
relative obscurity ahead of the primary
elections back in June to become the
front runner in this runoff election
leading in double digits in fact these
uh these uh scores that we're seeing
here reflect very much the polls that
we're seeing in the runoff in the run-up
to the runoff election uh today on
Sunday we've now heard from Guatemala's
president Alejandro jamate who took to
Twitter to congratulate president-elect
Bernardo Arevalo of course what we are
hearing from political analysts is
listen to those fireworks people are
really are really celebrating right now
but what we're hearing from political
analysts and experts here is that there
are challenges legal challenges apart
from the governance challenges for the
president-elect the next few days will
be very telling and to get a better
sense of what all that means I want to
bring in a political analyst Edgar Ortiz
who's joining us here today and got to
thank you so much for taking the time to
speak to us today this has been a
controversial election even before the
primaries what are your initial
observations uh based off of what we're
hearing right now well whatever what I
want to see now is that are evalu won
because this election was a referendum
against the system so une
she represents the old system the old
political parties and Bernardo from
semia they represent this John Perry
that was born in 2015 when the
anti-protest movement took place right
here in this Central Park we have in our
backs so there's hope for people that
Arevalo can do things different that he
can fight corruption because we we live
this short period right from 2015 to
2019 with this anti-corruption fight and
that was completely disarticulated by
jamate's government so right now there's
hope there are also challenges for
Arevalo as you mentioned uh the public
prosecutor's office will try to attack
areva Los Pari and also Pro Leone will
try some legal challenges to these
results although I don't think they are
going to succeed in challenging the
results but they will gain some time and
maybe they will try
um to to see some doubts about the
elections if they can now we were
noticing something something that raised
eyebrows this morning was the more
conservative candidate Sandra Torres you
certainly
um has the backing and support from the
more conservative elements of Guatemalan
society when asked by a local reporter
here this morning if she would respect
the results of today's election she
didn't answer that question in fact just
moments ago uh her campaign announced
that they wouldn't they canceled their
speech for this evening how should we be
reading into this well first of all he's
very it's very funny to say to consider
Sandra conservative because she
completely changed her political
position over the years she used to be I
mean used to be a leftist party I mean
she she has photos with Fidel Castro
with double Chavez but all from the
sudden she's now a conservative but the
thing is she knew she was going to lose
I mean she always loses in run-ups from
you know since 2015 no matter who is the
candidate you know the opposition
candidate she will always lose so she
knew she's going to lose and she now is
trying to see doubts about the election
she's trying to not concede and to claim
that you know there are some
inconsistencies in the system or that
some electoral boards they are the ones
who can't develop the votes that they
are members of semia or they had members
of uh you know the conspiracy of
whatever so she will try to fight the
election because she's incapable of
winning in the polls and Edgar there are
so many challenges that the incoming
president is going to chase uh be faced
with when it comes to the economy when
it comes to climate change when it comes
to Poverty which stands at 60 right now
worsening crime there are so many of
these challenges that for the most part
many people agree cannot be fixed
overnight isn't that right no it is
right and has a big challenge because
people has really high expectations
about what the arevolo can do as
president but the thing is if the
government of Guatemala you know you
think about it as a car if we are cars
with no tires with no gasoline and uh
you know
running you know driving this car is
very hard so for him to deliver uh
results in a short term will be very
difficult and people will will be very
impatient and you will have Congress I
mean we have to speak that later but
Congress he has a minority in Congress
do only 23 congressmen over 160. so it
will be very hard for him they will have
to be very very creative in order to
bring some tangible results in the first
three four months in order to gain
government ability because it will be
very hard to govern this country with
all the opposition they are going to
face and Edgar any concerns over the
coming days yeah absolutely I think we
may see some actions from the public
prosecutor's office I mean as I
mentioned earlier uh
faces uh you know a very dubious case
that the attorney generals brought they
brought charges arguing that back in
2018 when they were conforming the party
they included some false signatures over
the the members of the party and they
turned this case in a whole scheme of
organized crime and uh they they are
coming after some members of Samia in
the following days probably Edgar Ortiz
thank you so much political analyst here
in Guatemala a lot of celebrations
taking place uh here in the city in the
in the Town Square but also in other
parts of Guatemala City a lot of
challenges taking place all of that
tabled for now now is a time for
celebration Kimberly back to you that's
right the celebration but tomorrow the
hard work begins all right thank you so
much Manny we appreciate appreciate that
on our top story there of the news of
the presidential runoff in Guatemala and
the win by Bernardo arrivalo thank you
so much sir